hello freak [ __ ] odd watching some
pure giant so second hundred we got to
talk about is everybody keep saying that
you didn't tell the truth about your
interaction with Nate Diaz because
they're reading this transcript that
somebody put up the conversation you
have with Nate Diaz where you said I
think you're off on this that's exactly
I said because he goes you're wrong
you're wrong you don't know boxing and
then I went he went round and we're
going back forth and I go I think you're
off on that yeah I think you're off on
this or off on that and then someone
wrote in quotes we he teed off on you
that those words are in my vocabulary to
describe a fight teed off also I would
never disrespect Nate like that in his
face like that that sounds happy have
you ever heard of me doing anything like
that lady I would never do that and also
what kind of [ __ ] move would that be
you to five nothing to do with that
you've got another grown man yeah I
would never brag he teed off on you like
that has nothing to do with me that's
disgusting no no I've never disrespect
Megan so but so everybody out there is
talking [ __ ] you're talking [ __ ] on a
false narrative it's like some fake
quote that someone they might have
thought they heard that and that sounded
like it was more salacious so they put
that in quotes it's not what he said no
it's fake news fake news all day yeah
they wrote their own stuffing it's
either like they're fine for headlines
like it's like run job talking [ __ ] to
Nate and point him down you know
yeah and he's saying you know people are
saying you weren't honest
you